oh my gosh
it's here
hello everyone welcome to my channel
where today i'm going to be playing
about an hour of elden ring here on
youtube i will be playing more on twitch
throughout the weekend um i'm very
excited to check it out very excited to
see the world see how it plays see how
it's different
um see what the the graphics end up
looking like because they've been hotly
contested so we're gonna play about an
hour here on youtube and then the rest
of the weekend i will largely be uh
streaming um my link to twitch is in the
channel my
twitch channel is in the description
below if you want to check that out but
yeah if you watch this video let me know
um what you would like to see more of
and i can try and get to that stuff on
sunday when i will hopefully be
streaming it again so
let's do it shall we
okay
character selection
a warrior an enchanted knight
a prophet
a champion
a bloody wolf
listen
more i'm already stumped show status aha
okay
i think i'm gonna go with the enchanted
knight but i don't know what matt is in
this game yet
let's do it
uh
uh
oh
already stressed
comes out in february game comes out in
february
ooh
okay
well
i feel like it already looks better than
i felt like the gameplay looked
so that
is good
hello
the cave of knowledge lies below
let's go i love knowledge dude
well that's mean you made me take fall
damage
this is all pretty familiar
okay
i'm very excited
and also scared which is frankly my
favorite thing about
from soft games is how creative they are
you never know what's going to be around
any corner wrestling in a set of grace
will restore your hp and fp and heal any
status ailments it will also refill your
sacred flasks however most of the
enemies you've defeated will be revived
when you rest at a site of grace you can
find
sights of grace by going where the light
converges
that's kind of neat
beautiful
i don't feel like i need to rest right
now well actually why not right get the
health back
um
past time or just closed
did we just close do i have my health
back
what was the hud button
huh
okay
hello
hello
everybody in the cave
hello
time for stealth
therefore try crouching
okay thank you i appreciate that
um good
try crouching sounds sounds good to me
i want to watch that again
i would like to see the person show up
again
yeah go ahead
hmm
yeah okay i guess i like just found the
tutorial cave is what this is which
seems like it probably would have been
pretty easy to miss frankly
um how to crouch though nope not what i
wanted
no um
[Music]
not sure
it's fine i can probably stealth around
you anyway
try back oh you mean hit him in the back
thank you that's what i was planning to
do anyway but thank you i appreciate
that
oh that was easy
that was surprisingly really easy okay
great no same thing
oh hello there my friend how are you
today
what like what are you up to down here
harry
oh nice
how what
i'm suspicious about how easy this
tutorial
it's suspicious
i don't buy it
um cadbury i'm playing on ps5 for
context this is on playstation 5.
you can memorize sorceries and
incantations at sites of grace you must
have a staff equipped to cast sorceries
or a sacred seal equipped to cast
incantations casting sorceries and
incantations consumes fp
cool i actually generally don't play
dark souls using a whole lot of spells
but this game seems like it's geared
more towards that kind of range so i
think i might just do it a little bit
more often i'm gonna do that again
get absolutely wrecked scrub
try fingers butt hole
this
this has been live
for about 37 minutes
the internet ladies and gentlemen look
at him go you never disappoint okay
guarding
you can use an armament in your left
hand or in both hands to guard against
incoming enemy attacks
guarding is especially effective when
done with a shield guarding consumed
stamina if your stamina runs out your
stance will be broken yes yes yes that
tracks
why is it always enemy
why is it always enemy
i already killed him i guess behold
jumping ooh
they put the jump in the video game
why is it always jumping
i want to read this one
didn't expect jumping well you should
have it was in the trailer we knew you
could jump oh look at me go and it
doesn't use stamina no it does okay
um so who the [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
excuse you
how dare
get down
still finding it suspiciously too easy
she says in the tutorial but other
fromsoft games have been odd in the
tutorial so i don't know
how did you die man above killed you
you tried to punch him that seems like a
you problem
in every corner of the lens between you
will find fruits and flowers mushrooms
and butterflies and various other useful
materials these materials can be used
for item crafting
roger that okay i will take them
yeah i feel like
the game looks better than i expected
based on what we had seen previously
this looks pretty good enough to me also
i'm really sorry that i'm sort of
accidentally teabagging you i apologize
for that it was unintentional you just
happened to be in the way
um okay
it's fine it's just gonna be that dude
be wary of enemy okay yep
i will
hello friend
can you get it through a shield probably
not right oh you can't well
[Music]
i was going to try parry that and failed
oh
that's very slow
okay that's interesting
[Music]
that's very slow
huh
um
that's all right noted i've just burned
through all my mana but that's fine
fp rather one step at a time
switch right hand armament
but i only have oh
ah there's your earshield
try critical hit i'd love to
i would love to critical hit that sounds
nope
um hang on likely weak foe i love it so
much it's so funny
um we're going to swap that and we're
going to take it which i'm already
forgetting the button
all right lads how's everybody doing
time for joy
a joyous occasion
all right
sup [ __ ]
how's everybody doing
oh no
i'm surprised i didn't hit him though
that is surprising to me
no i guess i just don't have as much
range as i think i have
um okay
this looks great that lighting is very
pretty
i'm pleasantly surprised
be wary of enemy thank you
archer ahead that is actually helpful
visions of hope i love them so much i
think it's so funny
oh the internet
okay
where's the archer at is it you
it you question mark
unsure
well yeah i do actually want to touch
this bloodstream how is everybody dying
here
somebody just came over here
[Music]
mildly concerning
any big boy
skills or special abilities that
elements have there is a wide variety of
skills that armaments can have form a
powerful attacks to unique temporary
effects using skills uses fp okay
that's oh i don't know what it does but
i like the way it looks
good day sir
clearly i did that
not in the correct timing um
oh that's right there's stealth
okay crouch to make it harder for
enemies to discover you especially
effective in tall grass what am i a
pokemon
oh some kind of pokemon what's that
who knew who knew
um not quite that yet rock kick up but
thank you i appreciate it thank you very
much um all right crouch to make it
harder for enemies discovery is
especially effective in tall grass
attacking an enemy that hasn't noticed
you will close my damage unusual
not that useful when i can wait hang on
i've this is crouch i keep thinking it's
sprint uh okay we can just i can kill
him anyway is the thing you know what
i'm saying
be wary of rump
oh
god okay
so it doesn't have
an indicator like a lot of other games
do
oh r1a back to an enemy is a critical
hit that is good to know
um it doesn't have an indicator of if
they've seen you or not or like if
you're actually in cover or not
that i can tell
critical hit [ __ ]
nope that's what i did before anyway
probably
okay cool um
cool cool cool sweet sweet sweet wasn't
wasn't thinking that they would let me
through there but i figured i'd try
uh how good is your kona vision good sir
stands breaking some attacks may break
an enemy's stance giving you a chance to
perform a critical hit charge attacks
and jump attacks make it particularly
easy to break an enemy stance charge
attack while jumping i'm excited about
this jumping thing
that's exciting news
so r2 while jumping jump attack
i could stealth him but i'm gonna do it
oh that's cool
eat i love it
i'm very much down with it
that's great
ah i feel like that's going to be so fun
in the open world
hell yeah dude
the jump feels good too
and then i wonder if can you do like a
an r1 you can do an r1 jump as well
that's gonna be so cool with boss fights
with like huge bosses
all right what are you
sakura has made me scared of anything
that looks statuey
upon dying we revived it lost sight of
grace at which you rested however there
is a stake of marika anyway you died you
can choose to be revived there instead
all right love that means it's expecting
me to die through here
cool cool cool cool sweet sweet sweet
sweet sweet
all right let's go let's go let's go
let's go
hello good sir
you can perform a counter attack
immediately after blocking an enemy
attack god counters make it easy to
break an enemy stance or to immediately
have a broken attack
okay
it's all very suspicious again i'm aware
that i'm in the tutorial
but it is very suspicious okay
i'm
i don't buy it i did think it looked a
lot easier
but i also
the demon souls reveal trailer also
looked pretty easy
we're in the tutorial ladies and
gentlemen we are in the tutorial
this game has a tutorial which is
obviously super exciting
um
well people died up here somehow
i did it expect weak [ __ ]
i don't believe you oh okay okay that we
just finished the tutorial i think what
happened to you what happened to you
idiot
[Laughter]
what happened how did you die
you all just ran off the cliff
you all just ran off the cliff
why did you do that
oh my god these dummies how did you die
did you also just run off a cliff oh no
you somebody
you did
oh my god okay um just jump down here
and i'm gonna guess go up here i feel
like i should be looting but i've not
seen any indication of like there being
a lot of loot presents so
let's roll
visions of a great tree
i'm enjoying the minimalistic hud also
i think that that is quite nice
hello
anybody
anybody here
oh hello my friend
touch grace
dope
i would like my health back
and
hmm
memorize spell that's right okay
with the memory menu you can memorize
sorceries and incantations you must have
a staff equipped to cast sorceries or a
sacred seal equipped to cast
incantations i feel like i should be
reading this in a more dramatic voice
casting sorceries and incantations
consumes fp
your memory slots determine the number
of sorceries and incantations you can
memorize you can increase your memory
slots by obtaining an ancient amulet of
course you [ __ ] can
um
i'm assuming that i already have these
memories this is a new memory slot and i
only have two spells so
nothing nothing so far um
check like menu situation
status multiplayer
the multiplayer menu you can use various
multiplayer items if you set a group
password you'll be more likely to see
messages summon signs bloodstains
phantoms and so on using the same
password
that's interesting so that's how i was
really curious how they would do the the
co-op but they've done it by
you could just set
a password
and then anybody like if you put the
password in anybody can
jump in with it that's very interesting
um
finger
remedies player back to their own world
oh
huh
called summon to play cooperative mate
player this sign will appear in other
places
why not somebody wants to come through i
don't know if i have to
um
oh that's really cool i don't know if i
have to like set a password for that to
work but whatever i'll figure it out
try gesturing i don't know how to
gesture
ha ha no no how how
good
um
i don't know how
who did you fight here oh nobody
probably oh okay
uh elton ring
i love it so much
uh this game has bad co-op in it like
demon souls games no i believe this game
has good co-op
crimson
um
i believe it has actual co-op
lever
no
somebody [ __ ] died here
oh no
okay
hidden path ahead
is it this
didn't expect gesturing i still don't
know how to gesture
um i'm just gonna break some [ __ ]
is this gonna be i'm just gonna stand on
it it's gonna take me up or what
that is just a wall
i wasn't sure if it would be something
i'm gonna
stand on it
hello
nothing badly
i'm so excited to see the open world
though okay oh no
look at all these blood stains
oh boy
are we not in the tutorial anymore now
toto
where are you stupid [ __ ]
i don't wanna watch them i wanna i wanna
i wanna i wanna see for myself you know
what i'm saying
summon sign disappeared ah okay i don't
know how all of y'all died but you did
um
oh
man
whoa
the colors that's beautiful
wow
[Music]
damn oh look at this cool guy
who are you
nice horse
man i wow
this feels like um
like the first time that you get outside
in breath of the world
breath of the world
brother the wild or you just walk out
and you're like
damn look at all this stuff to explore i
like how like
clearly there are all these buildings
that have been torn apart and stuff too
this looks beautiful
uh how exciting how exciting
how dare you not have this game just be
out
yes materials
hello headless friend
what's up with you
all right
should i be worried about him i feel
like i maybe
should oh you can jump
multiplayer you will need certain items
to participate in each type of
multiplayer cooperative invasion or
competitive competitor competitive huh
i don't know what that is that's
interesting
select multiplayer from the main menu to
see your multiplayer items
yeah i did already do that
i did already take a look at that and my
choice was to
be down to do quora cooperative
so now i guess is it like if somebody's
here that they will be able to join or
something i'm not really sure what to
make of that
touch grace i love that it sounds so
much like touch grass
just go touch some grace will you just
touch grace bro oh my god we're getting
so many donations for movember thank you
all so much what the heck 1149.
[Music]
um
thank you killakillah
626 donated a thousand dollars that's
incredible um okay i summoned somebody
hey
what's up
hello do you want to go kill mans should
we go kill this guy
what like what do you want to do
you want to like hang out
i love it okay
do you want to oh we're summoning
someone else as well
cool
you said on able last time but it did
though
hey do you want to do we want to kill
this dude
like what are you trying to do
could this be a tree
try parrying i'd love to what are you is
my
can i maybe not interact with whoever
the [ __ ] that is because i'm in co-op
[Laughter]
i love it it feels like the he-man meme
where you're like pointing at somebody
and you're like
not not like the not spider-man meme the
he-man version in the song but that's a
really specific reference that i can't
explain well so i just gave up halfway
through
um okay hey my friend where would you
like to go do you want to go somewhere
oh there's a map
oh no that's the wrong button i i regret
i regret pressing that hang on hang on
nothing on it all right
oh we have two friends
oh wait that's an invader
oh what oh
oh no
are you an invader why did it say
somebody invaded i'm confused no we're
all cool we're all cool
there's the invader
y'all we gotta we gotta we gotta kill
this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i've swapped out my staff
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not doing any damage no that's not
ideal oh no he found us
oh oh it's popping off it's popping off
down here it's popping off down here
lads i don't feel prepared so he's tree
sentinel and this dude is the invader
i don't realize that i put down an
invader beacon because i don't actually
want an invader
oh no oh no
swap
oh god the big boy came oh that was
quick i didn't even see him i was not
paying attention
i was about paying attention
we're just gonna go
the invader did get a really good ally
you're right we're just gonna go without
multiplayer right now i got a little bit
too excited however that is kind of the
purpose of the network test and i will
say that it ran very smoothly
um okay so can i pick this [ __ ] up i
would prefer to just explore at this
point
than to deal with any of that
and everything's fine it's fine and now
i can talk to this [ __ ]
oh yes
this man i apologize
i suppose so between for the elden ring
of course you have
no shame in it
but i can afraid your
well that's a brutal way of trying to
tell me
and dying that i don't get [ __ ]
you're maidenless
what are you
no you don't have any maidens
where are your maidens
i get made i
i got so many maidens you don't even
okay do we should we try fight him just
like see how it goes i do feel like i
keep forgetting to swap between these
two because i do love this stuff but
that's also important oh you can swap
even while you're holding it though
that's pretty sick
i did just get called a virgin right to
my face yeah all my maidens
my maidens are in canada
so
i see them on weekends
it's
it don't it's you don't
um
they are models in their spare time okay
what are you [ __ ]
that's the first person i've spoken to
is the dude who made fun of me for not
having any maidens man
okay
do i want to go right into a fight i
don't know i kind of feel like i do i
feel like i do but i'm also compelled to
explore
oh my god look at it
dude
oh my gosh
this is absolutely having the effect on
me
that um
breath of the wild did the first time
that i tried it
which is like
or just absolute all like looking at it
and just being like oh oh my
like i want to explore all of this
hello
who are you what are you up to
my bird friends are you guys chill
nah
nah they ain't chill
i'm really sorry about that i'm a
pillager corpse i guess i wasn't that
sorry what's up with with you
i kind of want to go to that tree but it
looks like it's blocked off so maybe we
don't go to that tree just yet
we could fight big boy but i feel like
you know
when you've just spawned in the game
there's no way it happens
you know what i'm saying
but that's also okay because i wouldn't
lose anything if i died okay can you
just walk up there
i'm not sure how to get there
oh
man
this is beautiful
i'm a big fan
um call out a mocks i am playing on ps5
all right let's take a look hello goat
friend are you killable
maybe not okay that's cool
what's down here
is that island or can i walk there
i think i can walk there well that's
where we're gonna go first
it's also very weird to be playing
um
a from soft game and to have less
enemies out in the open
like i feel like there should be just
like skeletons everywhere or some [ __ ]
okay i can't get there right now
um but i want to
all right i'll i'll come back for you
sneaky little island i'll come back
thank you cupi johnny for this up thank
you thank you thank you
i'm sorry i probably am missing a number
of subs because i just really did want
to
explore the video game
oh yeah i haven't even like gone back
for my souls i'm not sure if that's how
this works
um i'm assuming so
what are you
that's so [ __ ] pretty dude oh my god
i'm upset that this game isn't out i'm
upset that i'm playing it and it's not
out
ah
hello
what what is this
what the [ __ ] is that just is that a
rock
it's a piece of a building it has
physics no you can play soccer
you could totally play soccer with other
players with that it's going to be dope
thank you eastok
um
okay just stay up that big boy
not not right now maybe later
lost runes huh
it's not like i had anything on me
anyway
he is cool though i do like him
but yeah it's just gonna get get grips
with the world before
taking on such a chunky man you know
what i'm saying
i'm i'm aware that i can just kill you
guys but i still kind of feel bad about
it like i'm sorry
it just it's you know rpg vibes you kind
of
you kind of have to and
well did you not leave anything for me
to pillage look how much blood that is
i'm really sorry dude no i'm sorry about
that
look at all the animals this game has
wildlife
hello
oh my gosh
hmm
i wonder what happened here
i bet this game never tells us
i bet you have to watch 45 minute
youtube videos to find out what happened
here
music's also really nice and like
pleasant
okay
oh this would be to to save probably
after you kill boss man
what
who are you
santa
tarnished
i can see it
yeah i don't have any maidens
i know after my throat
then why not purchase a little something
i am carly
purveyor of fine good i think you'll
find you are santa claus purveyor of
christmas but okay
kale
sure you're a [ __ ] leaf
shop menu with the shop menu you can
sorry
with the shop menu you can spend rooms
to purchase various items
you can also sell items for runes
each merchant stocks a different variety
of items for purchase
tight i'm [ __ ] poor i ain't got any
cash or any maidens
it's been a dry spell for a lot of us
okay
i can get arrows
that's
about it
i don't really want to sell anything
about the nomadic people
selling wares as i travel
the land has been tainted by madness
since the shattering of the elden ring
it's only tarnished like yourself
who keep things from drying up entirely
let's say you're a very welcome customer
i like his little hand rod
what the [ __ ] is that
what
is that
an instrument of some kind
who knows
goodbye kale i think your name's [ __ ]
kali
sure sure it is yeah
at a smithing table you can spend runes
and smithing stones to strengthen your
armaments somewhere in the lands between
you may meet a blacksmith who can make
your armaments even stronger
cool
with the smithing menu you can spend
runes and smithing stones to strengthen
your armaments
you can strengthen your armaments up to
plus three at a smithing table
somewhere in the lands between you may
meet a blacksmith who can make your
armaments even stronger
tight
i can't afford it so
go [ __ ] yourself
can't donkey can
i can it has donkey
donkey has a long neck
um all right
i guess
we will continue upward
so are these pieces of the ring that i
like to call things that are
that are broken
no i think they're buildings
don't take santa's donkey i'll do what i
want
how dare you
how to get up
can i go in water
dude
this is so pretty
i just love color you know what i'm
saying are you gonna attack me piece of
[ __ ]
what are you
toasty
[Music]
toasty
oh no oh no no no no thank you
[ __ ] off with that
stop it bloody could you bloody stop it
mate
i'm not having that
all right
time for critical hit
whoa
what
get over here
[Music]
all right that's fine you too
maybe i will use magic a lot more in
this than
i generally otherwise do
these otherwise didn't have anything for
me to loot so
a turtle
a turtle
hello
hello my friend are you aware of how
much you can ejaculate
have you ever seen a turtle ejaculate
it's excessive
but do you think they know
are you out here with no maidens also
like it's hot out here dude it's hot out
here
it's tough
gold's tinged extra man that is
definitely [ __ ]
i just for sure picked up [ __ ]
it's all right oh okay
this is this looks maybe like a little
bit spicy that man is definitely on
patrol
it's a tortoise
it says first time chat from satan 69
underscore 420 that's a tortoise i love
the first thing that you wrote
you know my twitch channel ever was
actually that's a tortoise
it's fair
glad to know but also that's funny
um all right how many you [ __ ] is
what who what are you why are you
suddenly attackable no get out of here
it was odd didn't let me change
initially oh you can't change while you
crouch perhaps
mayhaps that is the rule
good sir
all right let's kill this man
ah
rump
and then
we will take this one
he's probably going to turn around
maybe not
oh a hog
a [ __ ] hog the hog ran away
all right
cool i love flowers
all about botany okay
oh what's this
this is a dungeon oh no
oh boy i'm not going to read any
messages because here's the thing i
don't actually know if any any anything
carries over from the network test so in
theory if i just like run in places and
die i'd prefer to
explore things and see more of the game
than to like try to beat things or not
go to things because i'm worried they'll
be too hard so let's just like
explore let's just get it done and not
play it like i will in my own
playthrough i feel like that's a good
idea
you just see what happens you know what
i'm saying
summoning pools
cool
uh oh
uh oh
[Music]
[ __ ] cheese your ass probably not
your ass though oh that's too many asses
to cheese
all right
oh look at you getting dodgy
who do you think you are
okay that was fine
how are these i'm getting wigged out
because everybody's dying
but in reality it's
that was actually pretty sick that felt
very assassin's creed um it's maybe just
that they're not playing defensively
maybe they aren't
usually souls please i don't know
i don't know what's going on here
twin blade great character in the fable
series shout out to fable tell him my
tiny friend
didn't think that would work but i
thought we'd try anyway
all right
this is where we came from right yeah is
there any loot what are the green ones i
wonder
is this lootable what are you
cave moss
love that for me
it wasn't locked on
that was unfair
that was rude you're gonna crawl out of
your hole and then get me twice two
whole times
not on my watch
cool
what's going on down here
wow thank you
i also thought it was well done
appreciate that very nice of you very
nice of you
all right
try sorcery
try parrying
and then this could be a weak photo try
god counter
okay let's let's see what the [ __ ] in
here then
who are you
big swingy boy huh
that's what you're about
oh that was cool wow that's
an excessive amount of range
they seem to have more animations oh
[ __ ] i didn't think you'd even try me
there mate um they seem to have more
animations than i feel like your usual
from soft game
oh that was the wrong button
that's what i wanted to do
did that hit him i didn't even see what
it did
no no no
oh yeah just doesn't do very much that's
fine
i'm gonna go back to the shield
oh no i thought you'd break damn it
nope nope nope nope that
his design is pretty neat like i like
his cute little moss
i can do that too
look at me go that uses a lot of stamina
though
the jump hit
i think it does
oh no it doesn't it's not that bad
who gave you that much range sir
pipe down
oh cool
look at what i did
[ __ ] chill out [ __ ]
oh i thought that i'd be able to pull
that off i did not pull it off
i'm taking risks because i want to do
cool [ __ ]
oh that's right i'm out
i didn't know that oh no oh
harsh but fair
he was cool i liked him he looked neat
his his face looks
oh i thought it was a mosque it's
actually just his face
he's just got like lipstick and big old
teeth
all right i'm sorry mate i didn't mean
to i was just exploring
i didn't really want to come in here and
kill you
no
[Music]
so this is i guess there there are
dungeons inside of this um
i guess like maybe they'll have
boss fights
i don't actually know
like if the dungeons are supposed to be
boss specific or
i'm not sure
um but yes the combat definitely like
based on that feels very similar to any
other dark souls game
um
but like with more flourish i i i like
it um sakura is my favorite in terms of
combat though i love bloodborne speed as
well
but like
i forgot about the [ __ ] hair man i'm
just
all over the place today
get out of my face um
the
what are they called like summon things
with a big old sword that i summoned
um i'm still not entirely sure like how
to paste that that definitely feels like
something you're gonna need to learn
which is really neat but um
i would say faster than dark souls java
walkie that is correct to me i think
maybe they won't all will just be full
of traps yeah some of them might just
have traps i don't know we'll see
um you can find crystal tears at the
basis of minor earth trees and elsewhere
throughout the lands between at sites of
grace you can mix two crystal teas in
the flask of wondrous
fisic this will allow you to create
elixirs very custom effects okay there
are a lot of systems too so like i'm
definitely thinking there's a lot to
learn here
why is it always cold
um which feels overwhelming
right now considering we only have like
limited amounts of time to play the
thing
but um
but nice
oh very good
i love that what does it say you have to
be standing on it
[ __ ] you
all right
um back to cave entrance let's go
yes
interested to see how quick this loads
very quickly
this is on ps5 i'm playing on ps5
um
that was pretty speedy
hello friend
you're stupid
i feel like so far this feels easy
but
i'm obviously in a starting area so oh
i'm sorry for i didn't mean to kill you
sorry about that my friend
okay
shall we just keep exploring see what's
going on what's up down here and all
that
some kind of camp
i would like to repair my flasks so
let's
go back to the church i think it was
wherever we found santa
you can do that
thank you lovers
skillup said the magic is op and you can
run away in which makes it easier in
general interesting
i'm gonna ask ralph to make another
podcast with me pretty soon actually
it will be ralph content i was gonna ask
um the same group that i had last name
jake baldino
ralph and um
to uh
debate game of the year it should be fun
i'll probably do that live on twitch and
then i'll throw it up on youtube the
next day
um i yeah so i i actually like always
love playing as like usually like a
battle mage type in virtually any rpg
where i usually use a sword and mana or
magic
i don't generally in dark souls though
because i've often felt like i didn't
like the magic as much whereas in this
i'm obviously already using it a fair
amount so
i'll probably get the uh balance that i
generally like to play in an rpg which
is nice that feels cool
hey steve welcome
how does everything feel um it feels
very familiar
very familiar
to your map you can instantly travel to
the sides of gracie you just go there
are some dungeons in other areas where
they cannot be done that makes sense
i'm just trying to refill my [ __ ]
thank you good so
my flaws got refilled too right yeah
all right
um let's go to that camp let's check it
out
see what's going on
good day sir
i said good day
good day to you
and good night
i think you know it's funny i'm gonna
upload this to youtube i realized that
the other two um
souls gameplays that i have
are both drunk
which naturally makes you terrible at
these games even like a little bit drunk
i'm pretty bad i'm better at sakura
drunk than i am at demon souls that was
terrible
um yeah drunk demon souls was a disaster
drunk sakura i'm i'm a little bit more
apt at but still still not great
this one's seven there you go everybody
my first sober from soft gameplay
y'all are dumb try hitting a little bit
faster and this would all be very
different for you
this it's on you i don't know what to
tell you
what are you looking at
did you think there'd be somebody in
this shrub
thinking poop
plants plants plants
ruined fragment huh oh this is quite
pretty
and is making a noise
i hope that would be a door
it's not
but it must be climbable because there
are fragments all over it
oh
oh oh who are you
whoops does this
it's a beetle it's it's
it's what the [ __ ] was
that oh my god
[Music]
what was this
what the heck
um i do not feel that way cormac i think
sakura is the
i easiest sakura is the easiest
um
okay
let's
just do it
i don't care if i die so let's just
[ __ ] let's just go and then try and
go through that gate there i reckon
hello
gentlemen
i've come to talk
you do have
a shield
well
okay i've
really pressed the parry a little bit
too late there that's a shame
i'm gonna try and get it right no again
okay that's better
okay
just a little earlier than you think
anybody else wanna come say hello
i'm surprised that none of you hug me
all right
i mean you just
do that
sort of shits and gigs oh missed
[ __ ]
oh my god that's so cool
what the [ __ ] man
you know
this is a real chest
generally when people looked at in dark
souls they actually are dead in sakura
those [ __ ] statue things just made me
scared those those the things that the
like centipedes come out of i don't know
what they're called the terrifying
like nightmares about those
vases
hola
um
okay
just because why not you know what i'm
saying
who are you trying to hit there
it want me
the ai seems a little bit dumb right now
i'm gonna say may i
oh no oh my
oh hello there
everybody's out to play now is it
oh i tried to roll and failed okay
that was my bad that was my bad
um
alrighty
oh uh
lost sight of grace
i think
all right let's go back
hello santa don't worry don't mind me
good sir
everybody's dead
um steve that is my second death
i believe
did i die twice the horse i don't
remember because i wasn't concerned
get the [ __ ] out of my shop
um so he does have a horn which means
that a lot of them will show up which i
did not anticipate which means maybe i
should try to go a little bit more
stealthy
but i also just want to get through it
like maybe i shouldn't even fight him
man because i want to look at the [ __ ]
that's in the town we will we will fight
them well i wonder if that thing's going
to be back here
that whatever the [ __ ] that thing was
the beetle
hello sir
it
is not here
it is not here
devastating
oh they have dogs too
the place is pretty well guarded huh
come on
[Music]
ah
[ __ ] missed
oh that's cause i've swapped those
accidentally that's what i'm trying to
do
ah
damn
the recovery was slow on that
that's fine alright
good day sir
uh how do i want to approach this we
don't want to flag the dude with the
horn is the thing
um all righty
just do some flanking you know what i'm
saying it's a little cute little flank
flank
uh
i could kill you first i guess but
i don't know i don't know if this will
work
i really thought that he would be dead
slow down
slow down
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
okay
cool so i guess you can outrun enemies
really easily which is uh gonna be an
interesting change
for a from soft game huh
i do think this is going to be a lot
easier
just in general as a result of of that
because you could split people up in
theory um i don't know how acute the ai
is gonna be but
okay everybody that is it from this
video today um the twitch stream did go
on like a tiny bit longer than this um
but yeah like i said at the beginning if
you have anything else you guys want me
to check out let me know and i will try
to like prioritize that on sunday while
the network test is still available but
otherwise
i really like the game so far i'm super
into it
i don't want it to go away